I just received to find go from a couple
of locals and life just butter to koalas
another by symmetry Sam Mitchell is on
the hunt for koalas
I'm guessing it's Randy some way this
creature is dehydrated and injured but
alive he's one of the lucky koalas that
survived wildfires that have raged
across Kangaroo Island which is just
south of the Australian mainland well
Danny man get some food into him koalas
are already vulnerable and with the
fires the zoologist fear they may be
reclassified as endangered an estimated
billion animals may have been killed in
Australia's worst fire season in history
nearly 30 people have been killed and
thousands of homes have burned since
November firefighters have been battling
blazes that have scorched more than
23,000 square miles nationwide at least
two people have died from the fires on
Kangaroo Island the place was a
sanctuary for healthy koalas until wild
fires burned vast bush lands leaving
little signs of life we will find a
koala sitting at the base of the tree
you look around and you'll say well over
100 dead and whether that koala makes it
himself that's a whole nother story
Mitchell's mission to save the islands
marsupials is about the future of all
koalas in the world because this is one
of the few populations not affected by
chlamydia which can cause infertility
and blindness
these koalas tend to be healthier and
larger than the ones on the mainland so
the islands koalas are seen as insurance
for the entire species only a few weeks
ago that was estimated somewhere between
fifty thousand koalas here and they were
all considered to be disease-free and
and now yeah those numbers are certainly
dropped dramatically get him hydrated
Mitchell says that an estimated 80% of
the island's koala population has been
wiped out by wildfires they're losing
more and more all the time
and obviously the Koala is
such an amazing animal we just can't
afford to lose them before the fires
about 20 koalas a year would come
through Michels Wildlife Park clinics in
the past two weeks over 400 koalas have
ended up here and the place quickly hit
max capacity but then the Australian
Army showed up I just want to keep close
on that all captain garnet hall set up a
makeshift hospital at the park he says
his team is approaching the situation
like a war zone
we're actually applying a lot of army
training here where we where we talk
about mass casualties where we where we
need to triage figure out who's
salvageable and focus on those these
poor koalas have have been in a fire
that swept over them they walked over
fire ground so they've got burns to
their feet they've got singed ears
sometimes that got burn injuries to
their lungs poor koalas have those great
big noses and they're just so vulnerable
to fire good boy obviously it's not just
koalas the whole island is just just
suffering I've got some of my staff
members have lost everything
Kim smart works at the park but she
hasn't gone back ever since she and her
family had to flee their home in the
bush it's apocalyptic I've just never
seen anything like it in my entire life
this might blue must have been a couple
of guys oh it was huge I pretty much
said to the kids I think our house is
going to be going guys for now the
family is staying at a friend's house as
they figure out we're next to rebuild
their home mrs. hon that was a cubby
house I built for the kids and let's
lift is a bit of tuna and some sand on
the bottom we love hanging out here in
the wild and everything
now I just don't know if it's worth it
if I've got to go through that kind of
terror again with the children Kim says
going back to work at the Wildlife Park
will help her get through this hard time
especially since so many koalas also
need to find new homes this is just the
own devastation because the ones that we
do really militate where are they going
to go
satellite images show how the fires have
burned almost one third of the island
eucalyptus trees are one of the islands
most common vegetation and now they're
just charred remains of what used to be
the koalas home and food source the
biggest problem we have is with the
habitat go on we need to re-establish
new habitat site so we're looking to
planting as many trees as we can
Mitchell says repopulating the island
has been done before in the 1920s 18
koalas were released in order to
establish a disease-free population that
grew to more than 50,000 koalas it took
a hundred years to get the numbers to
what they are today and that was when
when there was so much habitat here so
you know we could be talking years and
years before we we start to say the
numbers bounce back the fires continue
to burn not just the islands delicate
ecosystem but other parts of the country
rehabilitating these habitats will take
years
the kids in the car Craig and his family
will also need to rebuild a wife from
the play Rico he can't imagine going
back to the bush where the fires quickly
destroyed his house but he's certain
that the new home they will build will
still be on Kangaroo Island
[Music]